look at afternoon everybody
if I can have your attention we're gonna
begin our programming right now there we
go
of course that sometimes means I have to
kiss somebody when I hear bells clinging
but good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
my name is Lawson Bader I'm the director
of economic education with the Makeda
Center and on behalf of McKay decide
like to welcome you to this luncheon
featuring Hernando DeSoto by way of
background we are an educational
organization that is part of George
Mason University we're located in the
Arlington campus rather than out in
Fairfax
Makeda is an organization that is
essentially dedicated to studying the
role of markets and market processes in
society and identifying where and how
these lessons might be applied through
our Capitol Hill campus program with
which most of you are familiar we
engaged in a dialogue with you about
these lessons but we also more
importantly take back to our network of
scholars some of the challenges and the
struggles that you the policy maker face
and trying to implement and deal with
rel with rather significant public
policy concerns we essentially seek to
foster an understanding of how market
and other economic principles can
provide a starting point a framework of
questions if you will when tackling a
particular problem
our annual chief of staff retreat our
four-day educational courses and the
many breakfasts and roundtable series
are things that many of you have
obviously attended and that we will
continue to do in the next year we have
recently completed our 2000 2001
academic year in which over a thousand
of your colleagues on the hill
participated in and/or recieved GMU
certificates for our programs and we
look forward to expanding that in the
next year ahead this lunch today negates
our new 2001 2002 term he will be
hearing from us shortly and repeatedly
about the many programs we have planned
to the next few months and the year
ahead and if you need updates please go
to Capitol Hill campus org and you can
get information there Hernando DeSoto is
currently the president of the Institute
for liberty and democracy headquarter
lima peru the institute is a think-tank
which is committed to
legal frameworks which helped the poor
of developing and the former communist
world to access property rights and to
turn that property into leverageable
capital The Economist has deemed the
Institute as the second most important
thing take in the world which of course
begets the question who is the first in
the world unfortunately I don't think
it's Mercatus but I'm sure Hernando can
shed light on that Time magazine has
recently listed Hernando as one of the
five leading Latin American innovators
of the century he is an economist by
training who has spent a varied career
within government and economic
organizations including GATT he has been
the president of the Executive Committee
of a copper exporting countries
organization managing director of the
Universal Engineering Corporation and a
principal the Swiss bank corporation
Consulting Group that also very recently
was a governor of Peru's central reserve
bank obviously he has also served as
president Fuji Morrow's personal
representative intentional advisor until
some of the recent activities during
which he has been very much involved in
the miraculous modernisation of Peru's
economic system the stabilization of
Peru's economy having tamed inflation
and allowed Peru to return to the
international financial market here on
the hill he might also have some
familiarity as the author of the book
the other path
the invisible revolution of the third
world a book which is still a
best-seller in Latin America as well as
here in the United States he most
recently and his key reason for being
here was thought this afternoon to seize
the author of the mystery of capital why
capitalism triumphs in the West and
fails everywhere else which already has
become Peru's leading best-selling book
and is considered in the UK and the
United States be one of the ten best
Business and Finance books and is indeed
a privilege for me to have him here
we're going to have him speak for
approximately 30 or 40 minutes at which
time we will open it up to questions so
without further ado it is my privilege
to introduce Hernando DeSoto
thank you very much for your flaws I'm
supposed to talk to you today about the
mystery of capital and maybe try and
bring it as close as I can to the
present the mystery of capital is a book
that is very much based on the work my
organization does I think an act tank
which has to do with creating property
rights systems in the different
countries we are called to the book
actually draws on that experience on the
successes and on the failures and it
starts off by remarking that since 1989
when the Berlin Wall fell we all thought
we were now going into market economies
and that there was no way to stop anyone
and now of some 11 to 12 years later we
are seeing that all the way from the
former Soviet Union to developing
countries where there were Latin America
Asia Africa or the Middle East it affect
the system the introduction of the
capitalist system the macroeconomic
adjustments have essentially benefited
some of the more privileged classes but
they haven't reached of the poor and
it's important because we're about six
billion people in the world of which 1
billion are in Western countries let's
to say Western Europe North America the
United States and Canada Japan and the
four Tigers that's 1 billion people and
the rest of us 5 billion are somewhere
between the former Soviet Union Russia
and the Philippines and we're not doing
well at all
and so we of course had this concern a
long time ago and we thought that a lot
of the secret lessons the secret
architecture of capitalism wasn't that
well known to most of you in the United
States and of course in anglo-saxon
countries it has come gradually and
slowly over 500 years as the
institutions of freedom have been built
up mainly a lot of them through your
judiciary and that may be some of the
crucial points in the critical path
haven't been pointed out and they're of
course very important to us because most
of us that are outside the Western world
actually don't have common law systems
we have Roman law system statutory codes
so what we put in the codes is what is
what becomes law and where we don't put
in the codes just doesn't happen just
doesn't become law and what
we've been focusing on has been
essentially those who within our own
economies have been left out within the
non-western economies which are in some
countries - 90 % of the people as we
shall see and in some other countries 70
but it seems to vary between 70 and 90%
of the people and we have studied them
because then being outside the law we
figured that they could actually be able
to give us the information we needed and
that's where we draw a lot of the
conclusions that come into the mystery
of capital the other side of course has
been provided by talking to people in
developed countries but not necessarily
you the ones that are alive that are
used to a humming machine that actually
works on the cyclic of aces of course
you have your recessions and you have
your good times but on the basis of what
some Westerners wrote about when you
yourselves were developing nations
making the transition to prosperous
capitalists or market a market
economists and in that sense to us the
reading of the classical economists even
though they died 200 to 150 years ago
are very important parts of our
conclusions two of them the most
notorious ones of course were Adam Smith
who wrote and worked in the in the 18th
century and the other classical
economists was most notorious was Karl
Marx who worked in the 19th century and
both of them were at a time when the
Industrial Revolution was beginning to
form when new wealth was being created
that had not been created before and
they all agreed that the source of this
wealth with the increasing division of
labor before Europeans and North
Americans basically built their own
houses reared their own animals and
sewed and harvests at their own crops
but now increasingly they were getting
together in cooperating and dividing
labor among themselves today would
probably be called specialization and
Adam Smith Illustrated this by talking
about what happens if somebody just does
one thing instead of 40 things during
the day what happens if somebody does
manufactures just pins so start
indicating all the complexities arisen
actually making a good pin and if
somebody just dedicated themselves to
that of course
productivity would go up immensely and
the important thing there was therefore
being able to trade the pins with
another specialist who special who
focused on something else and all of
this increased productivity was
essentially what was going to create the
market economy individual experiences
where people learned to cooperate on the
basis of transactions and they indict
enta fide that as the market economy
systems in that sense they were all in
agreement
it is the division of labor that works
and cooperation among people now the
difference of course was that what
outraged Marx was not the capitalist
system or the market economy per se but
actually what outraged him was the fact
of exclusion for Marx capitalism is evil
insofar as it excludes other people from
opportunity but to him the antithesis of
capitalism was not a different economic
system for him it was finding a
different order in economic
relationships what he complained about
in the 19th century is that some people
were left behind and those people that
were left behind were going to be very
angry they were going to be a lien Aidid
they formed a different class and that
class would be unsatisfied that was a
basic contradiction of the capitalist
system and that would bring it down and
that would of course generate violence
but it's but they all agreed that the
market economy system and the forming of
capital was crucial that was also
another key Marx it wrote most of the
books that Mark wrote and we will find
out why that's relevant today in spite
of the fact that the falling of Marxist
Leninist the system throughout the world
was the fact that he emphasized as much
as and probably even more than Adam
Smith the information to the formation
of capital
he said the capital was a crucial
outcome of this cooperation among people
and what's interesting is when you look
at the classics and I did take some time
to look at them it's they have a hard
time or a difficult time defining what
capital is they know it's important
they say it's crucial Marx dedicated
most of his books over they were
entitled vast capital the theory on
capital but they were not able to define
it precisely except enough to tell us
that it was not money they said please
don't confuse money with capital
value and of course like all things that
are valuable they can be measured
quantified expressed in money but money
per itself is not capital troof of that
of courses we latin-american countries
who have produced an enormous amount of
money and had a huge inflation but
produce no value so the fact is money
isn't value value is something else but
what's interesting is after talking that
it was nearly a metaphysical thing that
it was obviously the result of the
accumulation of assets that could then
become commodities and could then be
monetized eventually they didn't say
very much else they said it was a really
a metaphysical problem that is to say
metaphysical that goes beyond physics
and they said however that it was
important to understand it in this
debate that lasted for about a hundred
years on what really was capital but
that it was a crucial problem never
actually solved it in terms of finding
out how you built it they never never
came out in the form of a recipe but to
prove that it was a crucial is because
they said it was the most important part
of economic system as a matter of fact
the whole idea of capital is the idea of
importance the capital city is
Washington DC is supposed to be at least
the most politically important city in
in any country capital punishment is the
most important form of punishment there
is so capital is the most important part
of a market economy and it's crucial to
form it and they also said of course
that it's like capital originally is a
word that comes from medieval Latin
which is capital or capital which means
the head the most important part of the
body so to us this was extremely
intriguing and we thought that we had
and that's what the mystery of capital
is in great part about we had to define
what this value was what is it this
value that comes from people's labor
that you managed to capture in the
United States in Western Europe and
Japan and which we in the third world
nations and former communist nations are
not able to capture and to sum up what
the book says it compares basically what
happens to things like real estate in
say a country like yours and say denver
and real estate say in Mexico City now
you go down a road in Mexico City or one
in
in Denver and you see the same thing you
see fields you see parts and you see
buildings and in those people in those
buildings people are working and some
people are sheltering themselves as they
live there so pretty much it's the same
function it's the same panorama but if
you focus in on what they're actually
doing metaphysically you start fight
that is to say beyond physics you start
seeing that the buildings in the United
States like the factories and businesses
that are sheltered by those buildings
are doing something additional to what
the buildings and the fields are doing
in Mexico or what they would be doing in
Kabul or what they would be doing in
Lima or what they would be doing Manila
first of all there's practically no
building in the United States which is
entitled which cannot act as collateral
for a credit but cannot be mortgaged
there is no factory that cannot issue a
share against investment that cannot
issue bonds if it so wanted to all
contracts can be enforced
there are addresses that allow you to
enforce the contracts you know where to
go to beYOU to have enforcement all
organizations of economic activity are
expressed in statutes that form
companies and everybody knows that they
can supply electricity or water to a
home not because they know where the
home is but because there is a system of
property that indicates who's
responsible and you can therefore
collect from them in fact every time
we're called to see a different head of
state we give them a list of a hundred
things that are that a house does in the
United States at a metaphysical level
that it does not do in a developing or
former Soviet Union country and we say
that difference in in what they do is
essentially capital you may have noticed
by now for example that I have an apple
here on the podium and that Apple by the
way is mine I brought it in and I've got
various witnesses
and laughter therefore it's my property
but if I look at the Apple from the
bottom from the sides on the top
wherever I look at it from there's
nothing that says it's mine there's
nothing that says well I can borrow it
whether I can pledge it whether I can
rent it out where they can drop it as a
guarantee where they can use it to
invest in something else there's
absolutely nothing written on it which
means therefore the property is
metaphysical it's not in the Apple
itself it has to do with our perceptions
and our perceptions are by now and a
general agreement a social contract
already in this room that I own the
Apple and it's metaphysical it's up
there in the air and what I think is
being terrific about the West in the
course of the last 200 years at least is
that you have been able to capture all
the aspects the economic meaning the
financial meaning of any asset would be
an apple an automobile or a building or
a factory on paper and therefore what
you are able to do that we cannot do in
the rest of the world that 8 cents of
the world cannot do is that you are able
to outline all the economic aspects of
any asset on a piece of paper or in a
blip in a computer and it tells you
absolutely everything you want to know
about the economic meaning of the Apple
that you cannot see in the Apple and
that's what actually gives gives it its
strength for example I just came to the
United States and as I walked through
your migration service Immigration
Service
they said identify yourself and I said
well very pleased to meet you I'm Erin
and Eau de Soto I come from Peru if
you'd like to know a little bit about my
education I can tell you it'll just take
me 3-4 minutes and what I've done is a
job and they said look will you please
do me a favor would just show me your
passport so I showed her my passport and
they were then able to see a bunch of
things that they couldn't see about me
my age they could guess where I was born
where are other countries I visited it
was all in a standardized form and then
I realized that my identity my value to
your Immigration Service was not
captured by my body it was captured by a
document and it was put in a four
that is ruled by law and that any
Immigration Service any part of the
world can understand I then went to my
hotel and I've been going to the same
hotel and watch in the last 15 years and
I said good to see you folks I'm here
and I'll sign up and as usual I'll pay
at the end they said mr. de Soto your
credit card I said but you know me for
15 years and they said please your
credit card so I my credit card
basically has on it everything I need
you need to know about me because if
they keep in issuing the credit card it
means that all the information I've
given about my income my property my
assets all my backup is still there and
they believe that and it's easy for them
like the passport service they didn't
have to keep me five hours interrogating
me it was all done within minutes I said
I'm gonna have to make some phone calls
back to prove they said well you have
your AT&T card mr. de Soto so don't ask
us anything just put the numbers in and
don't forget your PIN but I said well I
understand the United States I'm gonna
have a room this is not like Russia I
don't have to settle the share with
anybody else where's the property right
and they gave me a card capital and
value in the United States and all
Western countries is not only knowledge
by acquaintance it is what Bertrand
Russell would have called knowledge by
knowledge by writing it is knowledge by
description capital in effect are not
physical things it is a legal structure
that you Westerners have formed that
allow you to understand things unseen
about economic activity and document
them and outline them and express them
in written form in documented form and
that is where you capture value and in
effect if you look at a Marv at a market
in the Palestine there are people there
like 2,000 years ago I've been the times
of Jesus Christ that are trading things
you will remember the Jesus Christ
through the merchants out of the temple
because they had converted into a market
so Jesus Christ knew where the market
was what is essential about your markets
whether I go to the chicago's
commodities exchange or where they go to
the London Metal Exchange I don't see
people bringing in cows and steer I
don't see people bringing in pork
bellies and I don't see people bringing
in for any form of metal what they bring
in our papers that express that
represent the values
and that actually are more interesting
than having the cow in front because I
even know much more about the economic
value of a cow if I look at the title on
the cow than if I actually look at the
cow itself so what I'm basically trying
to tell you is that the capitalist world
is a very clever and a very complex
construction essentially made out of
laws that the capitalist system is
nothing else than a series of laws that
are brought together that allow you to
represent capital and allow you to trade
it back and forth to its highest values
and that that is what we do not have
from the former Soviet Union to
developing countries and it is crucial
how crucial it is is that can be seen
for example in the privatizations we did
throughout the third world in Latin
America over the last eleven years when
we decided that we were all going to
move from Russia to Peru towards a
market economy we did what the Economist
sold us to do we did with the
International Monetary Fund told us to
do which were the correct things we did
what is called macroeconomic
stabilization which means we stabilized
their currencies we balanced our budget
so as to have a fiscal equilibrium and
we privatized our different state
corporations and the privatization was a
crucial part and it probably allows me
to illustrate what I mean by good
property the privatization program
consists of nothing else than creating
good titles for estate corporations as
the private sector could buy them it
wasn't more than that
that is what privatization is about so
for example when two people of the
Institute my organization were hired by
the Peruvian government to privatize the
Peruvian telephone company that company
appeared on another telephone us they
went out and went to see BellSouth and
AT&T and everybody and said this
companies for sale and they wouldn't
have well they didn't even want to know
about it they said I don't want to see
pictures of the company I want to know
what kind of a property right I'm buying
and then when we showed them Peruvian
profit rights they said too complex it's
not like your passport it's not
structured in the same way it doesn't
tell me what I can do with them
you're gonna have to retitle it so for
three years we went out to try and
retighten not only the Peruvian
telephone company but every other
private
company that existed all the way from
Mexico down to Brazil and it's the same
thing
that the Russians have done and after
three years after consultation with
merchant banks with consultation of
course with the interested parties and
buyers we were finally able to create a
property title that was cleared and was
standardized so that everybody in the
market could under could could
comprehend its contents and the Peruvian
telephone company which on the Peruvian
stock exchange was quoted at a value of
53 million dollars in 1990 was sold in
1990 1993 for two billion dollars 37
times its value and this is not an
expert news story that's happened in
Brazil it's happened in Mexico we didn't
even paint the company we didn't even
replace the doors or the windows and we
just simply represented it on paper and
put it in a such way that the market was
able to understand it we gave it a
passport
now that 37 times is capital that's
where we come in and said that's where
marks left thought that's where Adam
Smith left off but that's the surplus
value that Marx was talking about
because all of a sudden that company
could do a bunch of things that he
couldn't do before we could now it had
shares we could sells the sales shares
to the Spaniards to the Greeks to the
Japanese we now could issue bonds it was
easy to recognize it was easy to
organize the authorities and manage it
were accountable and all of that could
be seen just simply in the property
title you would even by looking at the
property title also told you what would
happen with different inventions and
telecommunications in the future that
were not available today but could be
available tomorrow and it defined the
rights on that it allowed it to insert
in what Adam Smith and Marx would have
called it the division of labor and the
moment something is able to be inserted
in terms of a wider cooperation a wider
division of labor a more globalized
market the more valuable it comes
because it can be used for a variety of
things that you could even have thought
of 20 or 30 years ago that's capital and
80 percent of us in the world
cannot form capital so it doesn't matter
how much we bring down our tariffs and
it doesn't matter how much we stabilize
our money we
of course have created a better world
but we cannot form capital and Adam
Smith had a word for this he said all
assets that cannot generate this
additional invisible value that they all
contain let's call them dead cattle and
all those things that can be used to
generate additional value or what the
economists would call stuff that begets
stuff let's call a live capital and so
what we have become sort of experts at
doing in the world is making a map to
any head of state that wants to know it
in a former communist nation or in a
developing country of how much debt
capital they have and we start off with
a real estate because this is something
that the head of state sees when he
crosses his capital city or any other
part of the country in his limousine he
can see it and so the first stage of our
work is how much debt capital have you
gotten and that area that you've got is
debt capital we call the extra legal
sector other people call it the black
market some call it the gray market
other people the informal sector but
it's the debt capital sector it's that
sector where essentially the property
law that creates the whole legal system
that can convert assets into capital and
that orders the relationship between
productive economic human beings is not
taking place and usually when you have a
vacuum like that it's taken over by
tribes by simple people by local
neighborhood arrangements or mafias it's
wide open it's a vacuum that immediately
somebody comes to occupy if you don't
get a regulate it if you don't get a
legal free market which you get
generally is a black market and that is
of course part of your history but I
won't get into that because we have
limited time all Western countries went
through black markets before they became
the orderly markets there are today all
you have to see is the Clint Eastwood
film to see that you were shooting each
other as much as we are today a hundred
years and a hundred and fifty years ago
it was very unorganized and it took time
to get to where it is today and it has
consequences in today's policies I
thought it would be interesting if I
showed you what it is we do when we meet
a head of state and we have finished the
first part of our task of how big the
dead capital sector is and usually what
we do is then I'll give you one example
because I'm authorized to do so by
the Egyptian government for which we are
now working over three years to design a
reform program to make property
accessible for everybody the first stage
consists of sighs explained before of an
outline of how much of that capitalists
and usually we give it in about four
volumes but we also give it a page with
five drawings five images the idea is
that you can go through a council of
ministers through a cabin a meeting very
quickly and in that cabin a meeting in
ten minutes everybody should have been
able to understand the concept
politicians generally of course don't
have much time to focus on things so
it's very important as you all know to
make the report 6:00 int so I'll go and
talk about that for a while in front of
the overhead projector in the case of
Egypt the first thing we presented to
the Egyptian government was maps of all
their different cities Alexandria tandra
s1 and Cairo of course it one only talks
about this tool on one basis of one city
and we asked them if they recognized the
map and they said of course this is
Cairo there's a river there's the Nile
going through it we can end as we can
see it but what we don't understand are
the color codes we said well you'll see
that there are nine color codes these
are the different way of people holding
their assets their apples extra legally
outside the law in other words these are
different ways of Oregon for human
beings organizing themselves according
to customary or local arrangements that
are outside Egypt's legal law and we
also have a map of where their
industries are a Parral manufacturing
automobile repairs we know where they
are it's very simple if it's 80% of the
economy that's where most people shop to
find out where the black market is all
you have to do is visit it you know we
don't do you shouldn't only use the
sopranos to get an idea of what the
black market is there's a very big wide
open market where anybody can visit it
just nobody thinks of bringing the
information together in other words in
developing countries the black market is
the market in your case it's the
minorities the hidden each's of society
in our case it's very easy to find out
then the question is what is represented
by these maps let's start off with real
estate here you get the nine categories
of real estate that are held extra
legally in Egypt I know it's kind of
hard to see but let me describe them to
you the first image on the upper left
are constructions built on agricultural
land and when we told this of course for
Egyptian friends but there were
constructions on agricultural land they
said this is not only extra legal this
is unconstitutional because we only have
one river and there's not much
agricultural land so it's forbidden to
build on agricultural land according to
the constitution of Egypt and so of
course it's extra legal and of course
it's dead capital how much of there is
there of this is there we said well
we've measured it with our Egyptian
colleagues it's taken us a year but we
found out that there's four million
seven hundred thousand buildings on
agricultural land so it's a lot as a
matter of fact it's a third of the
Egyptian population and then we said how
much is each building well we've done
with quantity surveyors reliable ones
Egyptian ones that have been countered
checked by foreign experts we found out
it's about ten thousand five hundred
dollars of dead capital in each building
in terms of the replaceable amounts of
bricks and mortar and ayran you multiply
that by four point seven million that
makes about fifty billion dollars of
that capital that cannot be used for
mortgages that you can't leverage that
you can't rent legally that you can't
sell or you can sell at a very much
lower price than it deserves when we
keep on going down and we start seeing
of course constructions on sem trees
lots of cemeteries lots of history in
Egypt so there's a lot of construction
there and then of course we get to the
middle of which are public buildings and
somebody says now wait a second those
are public buildings built by government
for poor people so how can you consider
that extra legal well in this particular
case you will see that these public
housing buildings were constructed it's
about they were constructed say some
twenty years ago but there were only
three stories and as you can see by the
picture they now have six stories so the
question is who builds stories four five
and six
the people who built stories 4 5 & 6
were people in stories 1 2 & 3 and
obviously it was a good business so
they're probably no longer there they've
moved on to something somewhere else
where they still considered constructing
stories above what is illegally
accountable to them so if you go back to
the records to find out who owns what
whether you're gonna give them a
mortgage or whether you're persecuting
terrorists the records don't tell you
who is where it makes life generally
difficult governance difficult and
certainly the creation of capital
impossible and you take all of this all
of the value of this construction
together how much do you get you get
that Egypt just in extra legal housing
has got two hundred and forty-one
billion dollars and I'd like to say by
the way that the figures I'm giving you
on Egypt are strictly an example it's
the same situation Peru it's the same
situation the Philippines it's a very
similar situation in Mexico and now that
hopefully we're going to begin working
in Russia we'll probably find that it
has some similitudes now 241 billion
dollars are owned by roughly 90% of the
population is to say that all the people
who own homes you need to do not have
per their homes on the records or the
buildings on the record in the case of
90% of the population so we're not
talking about something marginal we're
talking about being the brunt of the
economy well 241 billion dollars is a
lot of money is a little amount of money
well it's 55 times more money and all
the investment in Egypt over the last
200 years including the Suez Canal in
the ass one time and the ass went down
55 times more it's 30 times bigger than
the Cairo stock exchange and it's 116
times bigger than all privatizations and
it's 70 times bigger than all foreign
aid ever received so what this tells you
that they're in a very similar situation
which you Americans were at the end of
the 18th and 19th century which is you
had an enormous amount of wealth but it
wasn't illegal economy yet and of course
it couldn't be plugged into the banking
system and of course you couldn't create
capital and it was a very violent place
what it tells you basically is that the
poor today in developing conditions and
in former communist nations are not the
problem this poor are the solution and
what we try and do in every country Oh
he's essentially passed the agenda of
the port from the desk of the first lady
who was dedicated to charity to the desk
of the president who's dedicated to
policy because this is not marginal
stuff that's where all the potential
these countries are it's not a question
of aiding them more it's a question of
enabling them more because even outside
the law they have been able to create
much more than what they receive from
abroad public or private and they have
been able to do much more than even the
private sector at home and the figures
don't differ from country to country
that we've gone to the problem is that
for the moment were the only ones that
measure the tendency of course at that
time of of the government you see this
is wondering why it is that these people
have not entered the legal system they
say well my god ever since even the
British when we were British colony we
set up recording systems why don't they
just start off by entering the threshold
of the law which is saying I am present
here is my home here's my house here's
my factory include me in the legal
system and we say well we've tried to
look at that as well so we've looked at
the situation of Egyptian law in
relationship to the poor of what happens
to these people who have built 90
percent of the country or 90 percent of
the physical infrastructure wanted to
enter the legal system for example what
would happen if somebody wanted to build
a home or a hundred homes honest and
unity to end Egyptians from what we've
seen even have more sand than we
Peruvian so what happens if they want to
enter the system and we've calculated it
and here it is it takes to enter the
system 207 legal steps there's - 700 and
207 contracts with the government you
have to visit 31 different government
offices and the whole process takes 17
years by this time of course our
Egyptian colleagues were very depressed
and we say please don't be depressed for
us Peruvians it takes 21 years and in
Manila it's 54 years what has happened
over time and this is the the important
thing what has happened over time is
that about 50 years ago when you may
remember a film I once saw by Walt
Disney Fantasia when I think Fantasia or
Fantasia when Donald Duck
visits Brazil and when Donald Duck and
sees Jose Carioca his old pal and when
he goes and sees another Mexican chicken
since that time we you could see Rio and
Lima and Mexico City and we were a very
small group of Elysee focused in those
countries and most of the rest of our
country were essentially covered by
National Geographic magazine and the
Discovery Channel
that was the hinterland come and visit
us were interesting were different well
those people were 90 or 80 percent of
the population in the last 50 years have
moved to bigger collaborations and so
port-au-prince in Haiti has grown 15
times over the last 35 years and why
Akhil has grown 11 times and Lima and
Kyra have grown six or seven times and
these people are now where Oliver
Twist's was in the 19th century when he
came to the city they're in the market
economy but they ain't got passports
they are not represented in such a way
that they can internet connect with a
larger market and therefore they're
forming large black markets were not
only mafias hide but terrorists hide
being they don't have addresses and it's
difficult to find them whether you're a
banker or you're a policeman and that is
of course the stage at which we find
ourselves now in the developing world
now the hoax challenge therefore at this
point is how do you go from being what
you are today a market that is
essentially a black market to becoming a
functioning capitalist economy and there
are results the thing is that we have
the the thing is that you did it you did
it from the 18th century all the way
into the 20th century and in one of the
chapters of the book imperfectly of
course I try to interpret the history of
the United States from the point of view
of a third world or a Latin America and
and I demonstrate to you that you look
then pretty much like we look today you
were pretty much a third world country
but you got yourselves organized you had
a fantastic legal system yet very good
politicians they caught on to what was
happening and it was a long process and
you required from you over 32 preemption
acts to actually restructure your common
law so that could adapt to what common
people were doing in California who
during the gold rush there were you
formed about 800 extra legal
communities each of which each one
created their own law and you gradually
brought them into the fold into a
unified system with only one system of
passports but it did take you something
like 50 or 60 years and you did that in
Texas and you did that in Little Miami
River and you did that in Oklahoma and
that's what I try to illustrate that but
that's a part of the history which of
course once you've done it it's so
boring in a way that there's that many
people just don't record it and the
Swiss did the same thing the Swiss for
the poorest country in Western Europe
until 1908 they were so poor as a matter
of fact that their Constitution until
today offers Bern the right to control
migration abroad that is to say to
control travel agencies because in depth
until 1908 the Swiss were being
transported to Latin America as cheap
labor they are today the richest country
in the Western Europe and those that
weren't transported to Latin America's
cheap labor were being transported to
the Balkans as cannon fodder as troops
for other Europeans that's how poor they
were until they got their legal system
together and took their 179 different
ways of attributing property extra
legally and converted into one standard
way of doing things the way the United
States was doing at the time and the
Germans were doing at the time so what
we've done is we've looked at your
history and we try to find out what is
it you all did the Germans the French
the Swiss the Americans to actually
create a capitalist economy that was
self-sustaining because the poor were
also had the right and had an
opportunity with it within it and we
think we've got a formula by now and
that's what we're starting to do country
after country with a lot of support of
course of the United States
now of course talking to dead Americans
because none of you who lived in the
times that are interesting for us has a
limit
they'd the bet Americans don't dialogue
at least not to us they don't talk back
so we can't ask questions and get
answers and so we said isn't there a
developed country today that has
actually done this and that we can talk
to some of the people that experienced
this so that we can find out if we're in
the right Road and the replies that
there is one country that was Japan
under the occupation of MacArthur in
1945 from 1945 it's about early 1950s
MacArthur at that time concerned
about the fact that Japan had become an
expensive and warring nation because of
the connection between the feudal class
in the military the feudal class that
financed the military said we have to
destroy the feudal class and that was
the instruction he gave in an edict up I
think two or three pages but he was also
very worried in the process because your
traditional allies the Kuomintang led by
Chiang kai-shek were being defeated by
multitude whose coming down from
Manchuria and China and setting up
agrarian reforms distributing or
redistributing property away from the
few landowners to the poor people
whether it was in a collective form
whether that could be considered real
redistribution is another matter he was
at least bringing it down to their level
and thirdly the Soviets who had been
your allies during the Second World War
had already started infiltrating the
South Korean Parliament giving you
trouble and so he had from Japan to give
a reply to that and the idea was
property for everybody but that's what
he did the interesting thing was to find
out how did the Japanese actually
structure this how did they get from
giving giving profligate yet to awarding
private property and this is a problem
because and this brings me to another
anecdote a few years earlier when I had
visited Indonesian I was promoting a
book called the other path and after
doing the usual promotion which is
giving speeches appearing on television
debating a few people I decided to visit
the island of Bali which I was told was
the most beautiful place in the earth it
was the other side of Peru so it was a
really good moment to do it
and as I was relaxing in Bali the
government of President Suharto called
me and said we heard you're doing
interesting things in Peru we have also
problems of bringing the black market in
and titling poor people how did you how
did you do it could you come and talk to
us and I did I went back to Jakarta I
met with about half the cabinet and the
president and then they said don't give
us this long talk that you once will do
give in the Sam Rayburn building just
give us the concrete facts how do you
know who owns what 92 percent of the
people spread in the 14000 islands of
Indonesia are spread there and we don't
know who owns what and I had to give
them a very quick reply because if I
didn't give them a quick reply lose
their attention and I said well look
I've just been in Bali which is of
course untitled and what you do in Bali
is walk from rice field to rice
they're all the different types of
maturation so they're different colors
are beautiful and they're all surrounded
by these wonderful palm trees and these
and this terracing and you've got the
pagodas all you do in Bali is walk but
while I was walking during those three
weeks are always new when I was changing
property because the different dog
barked and so all you have to do is talk
to the dogs because they've got all the
they've got all the information you need
and since then this is the way we
advertise ourselves worldwide just me
the other way around so we are convinced
that that is the way for example when
you squat it when you invaded California
and you took California away from the
Mexicans and all of these big white guys
with these big guns and these risky red
beards came in and took it all away they
organized themselves into 800 extra
legal illegal jurisdictions and how did
you bring California law into one system
you listen to them have you got it
structured and you did what you did with
your unified commercial or your defied
commercial code or what they're doing
now in the European community you found
out how each dog barked what they
understood to be the right and you
codified the whole thing and you created
one property law for the United States
and that's exactly what you have to do
everywhere you cannot import the law
from outside for example we Peruvians
have always admired how well the Swiss
drive and how badly we drive so some
Peruvian knowledgeable peruvian who went
to switzerland took the traffic law of
zurich translated from sweet Sidhu chip
into Spanish and enacted the traffic law
we're still driving as badly as before
because you can't take import the law
the law is something that is born from
the grassroots up which you can do is
professionalize it you can stylize it
you can structure it into a decent
document but what people have basically
agreed to like you've all agreed that
that Apple is mine comes from the bottom
up and that's what you have to capture
and that's what all your Western
countries did and so what we asked the
Japanese when we went to visit them and
for that what we had done is manage to
identify the seven surviving of Turgeon
Aryans who had done the Japanese
agrarian reform so called the grand
reform under
General MacArthur is asked them how they
listen to the barking dogs were we
mistaken
was there another way of doing it than
the ones we had if there was we'd like
to learn and we found out that basically
they also listen to the dogs and after
talking to them the seven octogenarians
for two weeks at the International House
of Japan we said now if you did this it
was one of the major political acts
because distribution of wealth is a
major political act and if it's a major
political act that means that you put it
on posters in slogans that's what
politicians do to take a very complex
idea and bring it out to something very
simple and at that time there was no
television so you must have had posters
and we do posters all the time and the
beautiful thing about posters is that
they summarize the whole thing are their
posters took us another six months but
we got the posters and I'd like to share
two of them with you this is what the
book is all about by the way but these
are some of the images you will not see
in the book because there wasn't space
for them
this is poster number one at the bottom
what the Japanese found out is that most
of the property held under the feudal
lords were the DeSoto's and the Royce's
traded their property all day long not
legally extra legally was a hidden
economy the only thing that interested
the feudal lord was whether he collected
the taxes and he collected the rent
so the real the real knowledge of who
had the rights or where the dogs were
barking was at the level of common
people and they found that underneath
the feudal system like in every country
in the world people get organized
spontaneously in local markets and they
identified that there were ten thousand
nine hundred of these markets ten
thousand nine hundred what they called
ku Bacchus which are Hamlet
organizations in the countryside or were
neighbor organizations in in the cities
and they legalize them and they said
tell us where the dogs are barking and
that's why you see the parcels beneath
them and everybody starts identifying
what oh-hoo-hoo belong what belongs to
who and what Factory and what shop
belongs to who and that's what created
basically the Japanese property system
as we know it today at the second level
above that field near the Green
Mountains these people elected their
representatives and their
representatives were able then to tell
the Japanese government what were the
basic rules under
which they acted just like in California
in the old days how is it that you trade
mineral rights how is it that you stake
a claim how is it done what is it that
people basically agreed to
what's the vocabulary because I'm gonna
organize it in a statute you pick it up
and you formalize it and then at the top
it's the Minister of Agriculture who
which takes the process in hand and
organizes them and then just below it
are the prefix who are or who are
structured so as to be able to dialogue
with poor people and be able to then
professionalize the law and that's how
japanese property law was created and
that's 50 years ago and that's what you
basically did all throughout the 18th
and 19th century and that's what the
Germans did and that's what the Swiss
did and that's what we got to do if
we're gonna get there it's not enough to
stabilize markets we've got to find a
way of getting the poor people and their
assets in the system or they will
continue to rebel us and they will until
you be a hiding place for all the wrong
sorts of things and for those that
protect their property rights once the
government doesn't do it the next poster
it's just as it's just as interesting
this poster by the way we had to
photograph them in Ministry of
Agriculture on top of tables that's why
they look as that they're part of books
and they are part of books it shows at
the extreme right circle the Meiji
Restoration being tone up in Japan in
the 1890s the Japanese decided to
westernize once they saw that the West
was more powerful than where they wanted
to imitate the West and they invited a
German mission that created most of
civil law codes for them and this German
mission created and since something that
was called the meiji restoration the
basic legal framework of the system but
it was a legal framework that gave the
rights to the feudal lords they were
feudal rights as opposed to property
rights so there you see it at the right
hand side being torn they destroyed the
system in the Second World War and then
they show a table where there are five
people around it their percentage of the
peasants of the neighborhoods of the
city neighborhoods their percentage of
the actual owners the representatives of
the government and they quickly
determine who owns what and that's very
simple
everybody knows who their neighbors are
and it's much quicker than anybody can
even dream up and then the next one you
see the new records being created as the
basis for a property system
so the threshold in which you call in
and the ER then you see at the bottom a
little old lady with patches receiving
her title in other words the people
being empowered that was Japan and that
was how it that was how it was created
and now you know one of the countries
that were working in is Haiti Haiti as
you know is the poorest country in the
Western Hemisphere in the Americas and
we had to go visit their shanty towns
and we were we were hired by prison era
steep to do so and we visited some of
the worst slums in all of America they
are the worst slums in all of America
and knowing now and being much more
confident as we are that barking dogs we
haven't visited one slum in Haiti which
we haven't found with a title but the
title is not issued by government it's
issued by themselves which indicates
what we were saying before when you
don't have a government that organizes a
free market there will come mafias and
local organizations that will substitute
and enter that vacuum which means that
the road what this means is that the
road to a market economy to a capitalist
system is a much more arduous task than
we have thought about it's much more
complex it isn't a question of simply
saying you have now freedom freedom as
Immanuel Kant said many hundreds of
years ago is something that is
inconceivable without rules freedom
without rules is chaos freedom without
rules is anarchy
it takes rules to define freedom and
make it an orderly process and therefore
creating a capitalist system is not
simply doing away with the bad guys it
is actually putting a lot that there
isn't there and it's what you did and
what all Western countries did but have
not documented in such a way that it's a
recipe book for ours for us and we have
to discover it and we have to try and
shorten the process let it not take five
hundred years like for the Europeans or
250 years like it took you we can
shorten the process the Japanese
demonstrated and that's what we do and
it involves of course creating a series
of organizations that you have and that
you're not
sometimes aware of but the reason that
you can do transactions so quick is
because you not only have property
records title plants but you
escrow and closings organizations
abstractors appraisers title and
fidelity insurance companies mortgage
brokers trust services private
custodians of document documents and you
regulate document tracking you know
where everybody is at each part of the
time which is a reason for example but
when these terrible terrorists bombed
you about a week ago you were able to
track very rapidly where they've been in
the last 3-4 months in your country but
try and get that same history for
Afghanistan or trying to get it for
Egypt
you can't the reason your police are
able to act so quickly is because you've
got an infrastructure property that only
tells bankers how to foreclose alone it
also tells police how to get their mat
and you've got this invisible
organization around you which allows you
to have an orderly capitalist society
with no black markets and that's really
our challenge and that of course is the
subject of the mystery of capital and
thank you for listening to me for the
last 40 minutes thank you
there is certainly much more that I know
Hernando could say I would like to say
but he is also most valuable in a formal
QA dialogue so what I could do is spend
the rest of the time asking him some
questions but for the sake of ourselves
who are Auto recording this and for
c-span sake I ask you to queue up behind
each of these to queue up line up I've
been with you already too much line up
behind each of these two microphones and
we will go back and forth between the
two of you with questions you go ahead
and start
distribution prob problem going back to
the dog barking what happens if somebody
comes and kills the dog and takes over
the land when you're talking the other
path you talk about invasions on land
and what happens if this land is doesn't
want to be invaded how do you title this
after this given the fact that you say
also in the mystery of capital how
lawyers sabotage capital expansion so
the courts don't seem to be a real
support in most of these countries to
private property what happens is of
course that the extra legal sector is
constituted or built through a series of
extra legal acts one of them are
squatting california-style
but that's not the only one the other
ones are violations of law for example
poor people to get together let's say
they're an agriculture cooperative that
buy agricultural land so everything is
illegal it's like having a car with a
license plate
it all looks legal but they're doing a
taxi service which are not supposed to
do and so what they do then is once they
take the agriculture cooperative over
they start building buildings on them
which they weren't supposed to do in a
variety of ways they start doing what
the economy requires them to do but
outside the legal system so once there's
they constitute like about 90 percent of
the population it is obvious that
there's a social contract that is not
written up and is quite different from
the law and by that the time you've
reached that nobody in my country Peru
or many of the people that I know we
need for third the Philippines where we
been working would even dream of
retaking that land they lost it they
lost it to squat
they lost such a squatting the same way
it occurred in in in the United States
the same way too occurred in Europe so
the quote you have to find out by
looking at the dogs is what is the
social contract the British did this
already even the 19th century in this
set possession is like nine-tenths of
the law so you have to agree even like
the Japanese did on forms of
compensation the thing is that the
status quo is not convenient for
everybody because whoever lost 90% of
the law of the land is about to now lose
the other 10% whoever had a legal shoe
industry and has now be displaced by
extra legal shoe industries is now going
to lose even more ifs where everybody
has an interest in bringing everything
within the law and when you make that
proposal you you're able to reflect what
reality is everybody then is willing to
come it's cut to come in but essentially
what you have to understand at that time
is that you are going to get rid of the
old legal system because obviously it
doesn't work the old the legal system is
supposed to be there to serve people to
help them get organized if 90% of the
people are violating it it means that
the legal system no longer represents
the rightfully acknowledged system and
you have to substitute that so when you
bring all these people pieces together
you start finding out that everybody if
I've captured your question correctly if
you've got to basically like the
discovering the barking dogs does only
mean where the metes and bounds are it
means what do people basically agree to
would you agree that we have to evict
these 1,500,000 people that have
squatted around the Rio de Janeiro
nobody will agree with that because
you'll start a major revolution it's
done it's the past you have to turn the
page but at this time the written social
contract the capitalist riddler the
capitalist social contract has got to be
built from the start so we are at the
time of the genesis where you were in
the 19th century where you basically
discarded although all of you Western
countries did and created one were not
only the feudal lords or privileged
classes could be property owners and
could amass capital but also for people
and that's the only way you know don't
forget the capitalist system the
libertarian model of the liberal model
in Europe was essentially a replacement
of the feudal model it meant killing the
old system and that's pretty much what's
happening where we are so you just kill
it and you find out on the basis of
finding out what the hidden social
contract is about
my questions very like the first one it
really was what sorts of opposition do
you find yourself encountering when you
try to implement your proposals and how
do you overcome it you've answered
already at least in terms of giving
compensation but that in itself involves
disputes as to who should become
considered how much which requires a
sort of prior to termination of what
entitlements are you elaborate on that
yes of course we spend about when we put
budgets our budgets to work we must
spend from about three tenths to five
tenths of the budget in creating a
strategy the strategy consists that not
other strategy consists not only of is
built of course on what the other 50% of
the money is spent on which is finding
out what the situation is like and when
everybody starts seeing that 9/10 of the
city's taken over or or more people get
a different view on things and what
their possibilities are as they move
along then the strategy consists of
communicating what is the advantage of
passing everything that is outside the
law into the law for the poor this is
the easiest for us because it shows them
what a building does in Denver Colorado
but it does not do in Mexico City you
can leverage it you can do all sorts of
things you can bar en't it you can do a
hundred things with it that you couldn't
do before so that's an easy argument the
next argument is what happens to all
those people who are in the privileged
classes what is obvious is there over
the 50 years we draw maps for them of
how they have been receiving and moving
and moving in those closer
circles inside the cities that are
walled up go to any third world cities
and you will see that people like me
live behind highly walled houses or
neighborhoods so thing is are we going
to continue retreating or if we can
start living in our own society and
everybody will have for a while agree
with you and what they'll want this
compensation is not as much as one could
think about among other things who do we
be difficulty difficult to pass
politically so there is a message
practically for every sector of society
that indicates that integrating a modern
capitalist system which and starting
again which is what we have to do now
and what you did when you migrated to
this great country is a win-win
situation for everybody
the end the only enemies end up being
those who live from traditional
procedures the notary publics of which
is only a select few in Lima there's
only 40 of them so they were at the head
of all transactions and the lawyers were
used to the old system I mean of 207
steps and that's what they did for but
then in those cases you always also
indicate for them and it takes elaborate
documents done by other lawyers it takes
a diamond to cut a diamond that in fact
they could have many more clients than
the ones they have today it tells the
engineers who have insisted that in in
the shanty towns they should be at least
17 blueprints per house that they should
reduce it to one they'll actually have
many times more clients so when you
finished looking at the when you
finished looking at what are the
advantage of staying or within the
system within the existing system we're
changing to a new capitalist system
where everybody has a stake in it you
have an argument for just about
everybody ever for just about every day
for just about everybody I haven't found
the last source of her since I said of
the notary publics excuse me that just
one last one would we do in many cases
since the lawyers of the most difficult
part is actually create two recording
systems in the country we keep the old
one for the privileged areas like 10% of
Lima 10% of arequipa Cusco and we create
a new one for the 90% and we create a
plan to bring them together after 10
years and what usually happens of course
is the during those 10 years those
people who are in the old system and
even the lawyers realize that the new
computerized system is much better it
holds much better it's got a social
contract behind him so they tend to Mel
it's just a question of using the
lessons we've learned from you for
bringing everybody into the social
contract congressman ed Royce and my
question would be this what could
policymakers here in the United States
do to help unlock dead capital what
could we do to help orchestrate a system
where we actually knew the ownership
what should we implement this policy
fine I think that requires a previous
that definition congressman the first
thing is that as you will have seen from
dogs barking and all that is
development is essentially a local
affair in other words would you yeah I
think you can do much but what you're
going to be doing or what you can do is
smaller compared to what has to be done
locally because it's it's a political
program it involves creating a whole new
legal system and under roman law which
is something that the united states is
for example not very familiar in how you
actually structure it but i think that
there's a lot that you can do because
you happen to be the rome of today it's
it's might sound grandiose but you are
the most developed country you're the
countries that everybody's trying to
imitate their kids in all developing
countries and they're working nike shoes
and some have the chicago bulls written
behind other t-shirts you're a country
that is admired at all levels and so
would you say and what you emphasize of
course can have an enormous effect so if
the united states dedicates for example
more resources to looking at the issue
of property bringing it into its policy
seeing the advantages but for example
even today when you are of course
thinking logically to retribute
terrorists for what they've done to you
you have to understand that you're gonna
not be it's not like a reat rebuke it
ler when you had all of berlin planned
out you knew where hitler's bunkers was
and you're going to the third row where
there are no plans you don't know where
people are so the risks of actually
getting innocent people are enormous and
the risks of great creating a backlash
against capitalism yourself are enormous
property systems are crucial to even be
able to enforce the law or enforce the
laws of the civilized world and so i
think that what has been missing so far
in the united states and that's because
you take it for granted is how important
the creation of your property system is
and you you've got other things in the
agenda stable money you've got that in
the agenda protection of intellectual
property rights you've got that in the
international agenda you've also got in
the international agenda privatization
you've got them the agenda low tariffs
the possibility of international trade
but you don't have in the agenda the
property rights of poor people it's not
definite
if you put it in I think that would
start generating an enormous amount of
interest and a sense of priorities in
other countries if you also identified
yourself yourself and your existing
prosperity on it the problem of course
is that you take it for granted so it
requires an act of consciousness and I
think that it would be immense thank you
thank you sir you've talked about the
property rights equate part of the
equation for releasing dead capital
appreciate if you could talk a little
bit about the other side of that
equation which is the evaluation
processes because it seems to me or the
financial having the proper financial
infrastructure such as accounting
systems and a good processes for
evaluating evaluating revaluated
collecting and foreclosure foreclosing
on the real estate that you're talking
about and that's saying you use the
Japan as a really good example for a
system that a country that's that's got
the property right system there but what
my observation now is that the part that
they're struggling with or they have
been struggling with over the last ten
or so years is the real estate valuation
processes and that seems to be a big
problem
not just in real estate but and just
business transfers and use the other use
the other example of the telephone
company that transferred from 37 million
and is worth four to billion dollars but
within within those numbers there is a
valuation process and that seems to be
the problem that that a lot of the
emerging economies are struggling with
including Japan yes of course the first
thing of course to understand is is that
once one gets into the into the
capitalist system before you're able to
to set up all the institutions that you
have to actually be able to give things
the right kind of value where you get
able to get all that information which
allows for the valuation process you've
got to do the kind of things I was
talking about before that's the hard
part and it's what's important is to
realize that the source of financing is
even at property right you know there's
a sense that I'm heading towards your
I'm heading towards replied to which er
which are saying you know there's a
sense
in many developing countries that
finance is a different thing from
property rights it's just sort of what
we call the Scrooge McDuck syndrome you
remember we all read those comic books
of Donald Duck has got a rich uncle
scrooge mcduck he's got a lot of money
he's got a big swimming pool where he
puts all that money he puts on a
Swimming's - and he swims in it and so
there's sort of feeling that money is a
separate reality from assets and it's a
false dilemma if you come back to what
credit money was you go back to Dutch
banking and the first thing that Dutch
bankers did was start creating good
paper good enforceable paper on assets
and they themselves when they had
enforceable paper then started creating
private money to be able to fete to give
credit against those assets in other
words property came first and thanks to
property you get credit money it's not
the other way around
and so the important thing for the
moment is to get that property unto the
books afterwards of course comes the
problems of valuation that you're
talking about and those will be resolved
with time as we start finding out how
you do it versus the Swiss to it you
you're disagreeing on something that you
wasn't about I don't want to disagree
but I guess my point is that I think
you're right you have to have the
property rights issue up front and
that's got to be dealt with properly but
the the other side of that equation and
one that I don't want to lose focus on
is that those once you have the property
rights
you've got the let's say the real estate
but it's it's the valuation of the cash
flows of really would drive the capital
formation because the the transfer that
you talked about on top with respect to
the telephone company that is really
based on that the cab the discounted
cash flows and and that's a part that
that from my observations that is really
the critical component once the puc the
biggest problem that these countries are
countries are experiencing now and what
I'm saying is that property rights is a
very important part but once you get
there I don't know how you you've got to
have a system for how to properly deal
with the financial infrastructure issues
you definitely do
it's a second stage I'm afraid I'm not
going to be able to enrich in you too
much because I don't know that much
about that part
in like I say in in five out of six
countries however the problem is the
first one is to create the property
rights system in place and then try and
see how you can perfect your financial
system but the financial systems are
working they're just not working as well
as they should and that will take some
continuing refining
thank you it is a rare opportunity that
I get to publicly thank actually a
member of my staff whose last day is
today and Rob McCutcheon thank you for
your work the last couple years with
Capitol Campus he's one of the key
reasons why we have grown and
professionalize and it's not often that
I get to do that publicly so Rob thank
you and for the next few hours you
but also it last thank you to Hernando
for being here with us